hello and welcome to minecraft although
today is gonna be a little different
spend spent he loves me so basically
you've seen all these crazy redstone
contraptions people built moving houses
but today we're gonna build a moving
meatball
it's that Reisman your fake friend
whatever I've never built a moving
meatball I'm not a redstone expert I'm
not even redstone amateur but I will try
I will try my best to bail okay let's
get up here so then you can't come how
tall should I build it this height no I
need to I need to be higher this will
take a long time by the way I already
know like the next couple today illegal
all right this has to be taller than any
mountain right okay
so with the new honey block basically
you can put slime and honey next to each
other without them sticking to each
other which means you can build giant
structures that pushes each other so the
plan is have something that some sort of
contraption with this pushes then this
pushes and then this pushes kind of like
domino effect of pushing that will cause
yeah I don't know what I'm doing okay
well this work okay oh my god this can
be so much harder with you spend please
I need I seriously need alright this is
a bad idea you just jump mad land you
can come with a meatball when I'm done
everyone ah c'est magnifique this should
work you push this those push each other
and these should be able to push a lot
as well there it is it's beautiful well
I got some big brain yeah I feel my
brain coming large we will do it like
this we put the cerebrum over here
that's a push and then we'll just have
something push this guy big brain
bing-bam-boom push that yeah
watch pop and how do I make it stop
I need to stop we're moving away from
spending I don't like this oh god how do
I make it stop okay we made it stop okay
so question number two is when we put
them next to each other does that work
at all it's an in theory we can build it
as big as possible I would just get
activate them both at the same time I
don't know how to do that will that work
no this won't work what are you doing
over there oh you pushed it you snake
that's fine yeah that works actually I
was just gonna activate them at the same
time give me two second game errs Oh
what they were supposed to be activated
at the same time I didn't know oh of
course they're really okay we'll leave
it's sort of works it's kind of cool
actually
oh Jesus Christ it stopped this thing
can't really turn around I feel spend
I'll be back don't worry don't worry
gamer all right we know that it works
vertically now horizont stop we know it
works horizontally now vertically
whatever I always mix them up but does
it work upwardly that should be the real
word for it awkwardly does it work
upwardly let's find out just so we're
clear I'm sure there's a way smarter way
to do this I am aware this is however
how I would get with my limited
knowledge okay all right upward testes
masti here we go
why you know there's an obsidian here
yeah okay no no stop that I did not ask
for this I did not ask I did not ask for
this damn it
go back
okay now where were we no I said the
same thing I have this help me oh god I
forgot the Obsidian okay
never again huh all right time to stop
being such a small brain we have to put
you there and you there okay now we put
a repeater one tick is Mickey one
tickets Mickey or should the top one we
tickets Mickey top one should be tickets
Mickey here we go all right I should do
it
three two one what deaf all right Morty
Keese Mickey then Jesus alright here we
go three two one that makes no sense now
I'm actually mad listen up did not did I
put the observer on the wrong way oh why
did I delete it all I deleted everything
oh my brain so small got a six pack
I'm such an idiot did I put the repeater
next to it has to be a further away will
do two ticks just to be saying hey to
one this will work
yeah oh yeah okay yeah
take those owls one boy I I wish I saved
before I did that started to rebuild it
but now in at least we know we know how
to build it now we just need to make it
go back to Savannah and make it five
times bigger is that gonna lag my
computer it's fine so now we have the
design we just we can just make it a
same way just ten times bigger I hope
this works I don't know I forgot what
was the design I think it was like this
I think I'll make it twelve by twelve oh
my god this is gonna be a beast
so something creative mode I feel like I
got to step it up oh my god it's gonna
take forever how do how to redstone
youtubers do it okay so quick test works
fine great why did I decide to do this I
hope it will work it will be I'm gonna
be so mad I've never done it so yeah
this is all thanks to the new honey
block in Minecraft
alright if I talked about that that's
the reason why I can't do this on my own
level this is the easy bit - god the
wiring I'll have to put in oh god the
wiring oh I realize I made a mistake you
imagine if I discover that after I built
everything I've got it's so hypnotizing
now we just gotta build all the motors
for it Jesus born
all right gamers we have the motor ready
Oh God I'm doing a backup now because
I'm not losing this so in theory this
should work in theory we need to build
like a launch pad once this baby starts
moving it's never gonna stop
no cool let's go back to my biggest fear
is not that it's not gonna work my
biggest fear is that is gonna not work
in a way that I don't understand why it
doesn't work
which seems the most likely here let's
get real I am so nervous all right let
me do backup all right you ready gamers
oh god it's terrifying
oh they won break no he didn't it's just
so laggy Jesus is ridiculous my computer
cannot handle they it's so scary I love
it did I do a backup I did a backup
right did I do a backup ok it's not the
most smooth looking thing in the world I
haven't really explained the whole
theory now we can build a meatball on
top of this and it that will push it
forward which will then some hens make
it a flying meatball so now I can
actually use course dirt well I feel
like this should be the easiest bit but
watch me [ __ ] it up
ok time to build a meatball oh what a
relief the biggest flying meatball the
world has ever seen
maybe we'll probably look social and I
think about it cuz my design is so
flawed but I don't care it means like I
could technically even make it bigger
but I think for now maybe later if I
have time today I'll do it bigger that
does not look like a meatball dude the
meat patch shout-out to mumbo jumbo as
well he does these moving house
tutorials and stuff like that that's
really cool I watched enough to like get
an idea how to do it ok this is the size
of our meatball but we want it to be 3d
obviously so I'm gonna do that
alright gamers you're ready let's beauty
is oh it's moving forward
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
the biggest flying meatball the world
has ever seen I am not sure what I'm
looking at but it is working it is as if
minecraft is saying no this shouldn't be
possible but yes it is
[Music]
Brod should can I stand on it that's the
real question
oh the evil laugh I understand my bill
is having this is so satisfying
peasants peasants dirty fools scoundrels
could probably make it so it bums stuff
as well on everything that he goes on
but that just might be too evil so the
deepest meatball where you can make what
a great sense the deepers meatball you
can make is 12 right now it's 8 the one
we made is 8 so we are going to make
this bigger about this much and then I
also want to try and see if we can have
bombs shooting down from the meatball to
make it the ultimate death weapon I know
this is a dangerous video for me to make
because evil leaders around the world
might watch and they inspire but you got
to do what you got to do ok so how would
we make something that bombs I don't
know because the top layer will move
with one tick Lance I might be able to
use that I mean another way it would
just be to plant the P and T and T and
advance I might just do that because
that's so much easier ok well if this
wasn't gonna like my computer before it
sure as heck in well now
yes destroy I just hear explosions I
can't actually see them the weather is
so ominous
yes I think everyone is dead I think
every are a kewpie explosions aah
oh god it's still happening it's
unloaded in yet oh my god yes time to
make it bigger that's a tiny meatball I
wake up early in the morning making
gasps sweet it's like I'm in the nether
cuz I can't sleep in case you got
amnesia man I want that blue stuff I'll
just try it and if it doesn't work I
know I'll know at least how to fix it oh
is it working oh oh it's a beauty it's a
goddamn boarding it's a waterfall crack
go forth my Chan explore the universe
see things that I would never have Shawn
yes that is a word
you're so beautiful I love you like my
child and father my god never respect
that anything so much in my life
[Music]
nothing can stop it nothing can stand in
this way this is how the McRib series
ends this is the last episode it's never
going to get better than this my moving
playing me but let me ride you for one
last time smash like and subscribe we're
all excited about the new game that's
coming out and I can't wait to play it
it starts with the letter P can you
guess what it is here the PI pick
sailing of course what you thought it
was Pokemon dumbass you stinky brainer
you